[Musique]
Noël est merveille à la ferme de Gal
c'est plusieurs weekends donc le dernier
weekend là va être le 16- 17 décembre et
euh on accueille les familles en
extérieur et en intérieur et on fait euh
à peu près six ateliers très simple euh
les enfants tout est dans
l'interactivité toucher voir les animaux
des décors lumineux un peu un rêve comme
à l'ancienne des choses très
simples ils font leur peties bougies en
cire d'abeille ils font une décoration
dans le sapin en argile euh ils font une
plantation d'un mini sapin avec des
décorations ils font une couronne de
l'avant et l'indisp enfin
l'incontournable pâte à pain aux pépites
de chocolat et on fait aussi un petit
collage de laine la laine véritable de
nos moutons qui ont été tendu en mars
dernier c'est pour tout le monde donc en
fait par exemple les couronnes de
l'avant faut quand même être un peu
grand avoir une certaine dextérité et
cetera donc ça les parents font avec les
enfants voilà la pâte à pain bah il y a
toujours un peu d'interactivité et en
fait suivant les âges les parents aident
beaucoup et puis des fois c'est les
enfants quand ils sont grands ils font
tout
eux-mêmes alors c'est 14 € par enfant
pour tout le package la visite des
animaux les six ateliers les lumières
les selfies dehors de nuit et les
parents c'est à 6 € pour tout le package
également le weekend prochain et le
dernier weekend le 16 17 décembre à
partir de 14h et ils peuvent acheter en
ligne les billets vous allez sur notre
site internet des fermes de
[Musique]
Gal